[Music]
this
is star talk we're doing a cosmic
queries edition
and you know what that means i got chuck
knights
sir what's happening neil all right
that's all right
so this one again every now and then
there's the bottom of the barrel
oh wow we we pull out of the barrel
all those that were solicited topically
but then
a few fall through the cracks and others
just come in randomly
and so this is just some brand it's like
a
a potpourri yes uh i think in the past
we might have called it a galactic gumbo
at home but we just don't have a a good
term for it how about uh we'll we'll
call this one
cosmic cauldron cosmic cauldron yes
okay let's try that a little
juxtaposition uh
tongue and cheek a little witchcraft
reference with science and the
alliteration to boot
yes sorry all right so what do you have
i assume you have a patreon question up
front
as always we start with the patreon
patrons because they give us
money all right let's do this yeah uh
this is davis
hemsath from patreon he says is there a
hypothesis
for the interaction of dark matter and a
black hole
so you know i mean yeah i mean
it's just because dark matter is dark
and black hole
is black black don't mean all the black
and the dark gotta vote together
as far as we know they are completely
separate and distinct and
as far as we know and that actually
i'm not even saying very much there
because we don't know what
comprises dark matter and as i've said
many times it's it'd be better termed
dark gravity it's something given us
gravity and we don't know what it is
black holes give us gravity but we know
what a black hole is so
there's no obvious connection between
the two
at all not only theoretically but
observationally as well
so i got nothing for you there well
there doesn't look doesn't seem to be
anything there there doesn't seem to be
a there there
you're not in the dark matter that dark
matter there yeah right right wow
and if you want to find out what's in
the black hole you can go check it out
and let me know
yes go ahead anyway uh julia
lychee uh huh uh-huh julia lysak
from patreon says this i have an essay
question for you guys
an essay question that means it's
compare and contrast
yeah that's what's one of those there
you go college essays essay questions
what in your opinion is the best
all-time depiction
of aliens in a movie or on tv
and why oh
love me that okay that's so cool i i've
got the answer 1958
1958 19 wait a minute with all the cgi
that we have available
right now that's the problem you go back
to 1958
that's the there you go uh the one of
steve mcqueen's
earliest films if not his first film the
blob
oh snap the blob the blob
oh my god it's so scary if that's any
movie
it's not snot is coming to get us
so the blog one of these you know low
budget uh
b movies i think they were called back
then in any case
what was intriguing about it is uh this
thing
didn't have a face didn't have arms legs
nose mouth
shoulders fingers toes head didn't have
any of the things you normally
would be putting on an alien primarily
because you have an
actor in the alien costume and
so why would
a creature from another planet with no
dna in common
with life on earth look more like
us than we do
compared to other life forms on earth
right here on earth
right here on earth so my argument is uh
what are two really different life horns
humans and jellyfish
and oak trees let's take those three
okay that's quite the gamut
that is whatever the alien is it should
look more different from the three of us
than we do from one another
because it's coming from a completely
other kind of thing
so that's why the blob for me which had
no
spinal column it has no nothing
it's got no nothing it's a blob it's a
blob
and another little known fact i mean
it's known if you paid attention
the blob was like you said was like it's
not it was
it was transparent
colorless when it arrived on earth
after it consumed its first victim
for the rest of the movie it was red
yeah that is nasty it became the color
of the blood
that's right wild it's a little it
happened just one scene
and then you don't think about it i
think the blob is just this red thing
that's right i don't really
because i'm i don't think so you
couldn't you couldn't defend against the
blood because it would come in under the
door it would do it it was coming
through anything
through the greats yeah of the thing
yeah came into a movie theater
terrorized people because that's how it
got in
for me that's the most um
that representation of an alien has the
highest sort of integrity
with regard to it not looking like
anything here on earth
now that being said there are two movies
maybe three
uh three move
so start with 2001 a space odyssey all
right that had aliens in them you just
never saw them you saw the manifestation
of their intelligence
okay so uh arthur c clarke
and uh carl sagan was one of the
advisors on that film they said just
don't show aliens at all
you can't imagine it right but you can
put their handiwork
and so that's one that did it not only
that in carl sagan's novel contact which
then became a movie
in the late 1990s because uh uh 2001
space august was 1968.
so so contact that
also had aliens that you never saw well
that's because
hi i'm going to take the form of your
father oh yes
he was like i've taken this pleasing
form to you so because there's no way
you could actually comprehend what we
really look like
right exactly exactly so so these are
i think this shows honesty
in our ignorance by not even attempting
to show them at all
okay and meanwhile uh a very important
movie
but for me showed very little
imagination was predator
okay okay uh predator is this alien
drops on earth and goes
human hunting right it's like yeah it's
what he does
and it's got arnold in it and it's got
some other
muscle men of the 80s right in it
and they fight this one alien
well how tall is the alien he's about
you know
six feet five or he's it's not three
inches tall
it's not 60 stories tall it's
approximately human sized
right it's got feet except they're a
little bigger it's got a head it's got a
mouth
it's got arms it carries weapons it's
got a belt
it's got stuff and this is an alien come
on now
so it really shows an absence of
imagination in hollywood anytime they go
down that road
okay well now what do you think of alien
so that's okay the sigourney weaver
we were the actual alien itself who
happens to be my favorite
alien because i mean you know because
he's
he's got a mouth and a mouth okay
right so if if the mouth with teeth is
scary
then you give him two mouths routine
exactly i'm like
twice as scared so it opens your mouth
but there's another mouth and then
another no also too the fact that um
it it bled acid to me was that's just
the coolest thing ever
okay but it's still like had a mouth
with teeth right do you realize most
like most life forms on earth
doesn't have teeth
i think are only invertebrates yeah let
me think about that
you know you got to eat something you
got to chew you got to chew
it's not only well worms eat things but
they don't have teeth
well they absorb they have no they have
a mouth but
yeah a lot of things whales that don't
have teeth that have baleen
instead of teeth you know right right it
filters through right right so
i'm just saying this concept that you're
going to make an alien and it has
teeth because teeth are scary
like i don't have a problem with that
jolts don't try to convince me that this
can you imagine if the alien tried to
gum you to death
[Laughter]
[Music]
slippers and a robe yeah
all right well you know what i gotta say
you make a very
cogent argument for the blob
that i never considered and uh
you know i i'm gonna say here's how
you've changed my perspective my
my perspective on this i
always thought that the blob was a lack
of imagination
really yes i always thought of it as
oh okay so you guys just you couldn't
think of a good monster so you just
made it into a blob but but the way you
explain it and i'm wondering if they
actually were as thoughtful as you
because if so then it's brilliant
okay they'll take it they'll take it
yeah if not if they're lucky that you
came along
well it was pre-ordained because in fact
that was my birth year
so we the movie and i are the same age
okay
right on okay cool all right here we go
let's go to
ryan espinoza from facebook and
uh ryan a little all over the place but
i'm gonna
give it to you right now uh he says
if the universe is technically
finite how about the multiverse
and the reason why i say law all over
the place is first of all
is there a multiverse because he has
made that a
fact which is not necessarily in
evidence so what are your thoughts
first of all on a multiverse now
secondly after your thoughts on the
multiverse if this universe is indeed
finite
would that multiverse also be finite
that's the question yes that's my i i
altered his question but that's your
summer you summarize i summarize okay
so the answer is
we got to take a break come back in the
next segment we'll
we'll get the latest on the multiverse
on star talk cosmic queries
all right uh cosmic rendition
cosmic cauldron edition
we're back star talk cosmic queries
check nice
and loaded so we last left off
on the multiverse and who's the
questioner again and the question was
ryan the questioner was
ryan espinoza and he won okay if the
multiverse was
finite but first of all we would have to
establish is there a multiverse
okay so first of all before we get to
the multiverse
uh we don't know if the universe is
infinite or finite we just don't know
gotcha and i don't know if we can
know for sure any more than a ship
at sea looks in every direction
and it sees the horizon and it
doesn't see land in any direction it's
in the middle of its own horizon
right it cannot know how big the actual
ocean is
if it only has access to the water
within its own horizon
what it would have to do is is keep
moving okay it'd have to like
travel and we keep moving and take its
horizon with it
and then horizon moves across the water
surface
and then eventually they might see land
at that point
they have found the edge of the ocean
the ocean ends because more ocean
doesn't keep coming in
so if we wanted to explore
if the universe had some edge right
then we we're not going to learn it just
sitting here in the middle of our own
horizon we'd have to start moving to
other places within the universe
and you want to do that fast otherwise
it expands faster than you can get there
and you'll just never know ever
okay if the universe is expanding faster
than you're traveling if the ocean is
growing faster than the ship is sailing
well yeah now you're
now you're on an oceanic treadmill
that's right thank you that's a perfect
analogy there
so we simply don't know so anytime
any of my i or my colleagues reference
the size of the universe or the
um the dimensions it's basically the
the observable universe the universe
that's within our horizon
we can give you the size of that and how
long we've been at
that beyond that we don't know now the
multiverse
it turns out the multiverse is on good
theoretical grounds so we didn't just
pull that one out of some
orifice right it's it's quantum physics
mixed with general relativity two highly
successful
uh understandings of the universe when
you shotgun marry them
in the early universe because quantum
physics is the physics of the small
and general relativity is the physics of
the large but the early universe the
large was small
right so if a large was small then
perhaps the quantum
influenced the entire universe so when
you have particles popping in and out of
existence or doing weird things
maybe that particle is an entire
universe unto itself if the universe is
the size of a particle
so you can take that kind of reasoning
that comes from that
direction and on in doing so
you can conclude that maybe we are not
alone that our universe is not alone
in a multiverse possibly an
infinite number of universes to reckon
so by the way depending on what level
multiverse we're talking about the
universe can just have different
configurations of atoms
and energy or even the same
configuration
now chuck you have a goatee in this
universe that means you're the evil
chuck
right exactly there's another universe
where there's a clean shaven chuck
that's the good chocolate
i think he's faking it
so that's one class of multiverse but
there are other classes of multiverse
um i've first seen explicated by
um a friend and colleague max tegmark up
at mit he's written extensively on this
there are other levels of multiverse
another one where okay
your the matter and energy
uh not only that can be different but
the initial conditions are different
so maybe your universe won't expand
forever maybe it will recollapse
then there's another level where the
laws of physics are different
all right this this is how deep into the
rabbit hole you drop
right before you hatch out another
universe what what control do you have
over the laws of physics in the
traditional multiverse that people think
about
we are in the same space time
just different pockets that cannot
interact with each other
as is different ships at sea would be
they're on the same ocean but they don't
interact with each other because their
horizons are
are separate and distinct so that's the
traditional
multiverse that people think about and
talk about and has been represented
in science fiction so just because
we might be finite or or open
or flat doesn't mean others have to be
because their matter and energy could be
distributed differently
so there you go wow that's uh that's
fascinating
stuff that is by the way people say well
if there's an infinite number of
universes and then there's you in
another universe
therefore you can in principle live
forever but no that
other that other yet it's not me right
it ain't me
that's not me it's just just as much as
you care about him he cares about you
see that's the problem and i've said
we've done this experiment before
with with copies of each other and it's
called twins
right twins are identical copies and
they walk among us right came from the
same single cell i mean the same thing
yourself
if you pinch one twin the other twin
doesn't say ouch right
so they're not the same person even if
they're
molecularly identical so
that's why i'm i'm not thinking that
this other person in another universe is
going to grant me
um
eternal life i don't see that i don't
think it i don't i don't think it's good
evidence
or reasoning to argue that way wow
cool well yeah that's thanks ryan
appreciate the question man um here's
michael scarn from facebook
and michael says the faster you travel
the slower time is for you
how much younger do career pilots stay
being if they fly and travel uh
fast faster than common people so if
you're
constantly spending time at
let's call it supersonic speed uh
is there any negligible time
just i mean time um
you can always calculate how much
younger they are
relative to their twin on earth you can
always do that by the way we've done
this experiment
there is a twin astronaut who went into
orbit and stayed there for a year or so
and left the other one on earth and we
studied
we i mean the nasa medical right
professionals
studied any differences in their dna
exposure to space radiation
and there is this factor because it's
going
in orbit you're going much much faster
than a fighter pilot would ever
right go yeah you're going in in fact in
orbit you're going
if you were to travel that through the
air it'd be like mach 30 or 40.
um and then firepox is going mach 2 at
most mach 3
right so if you're really you know
really booking it so you can calculate
you just plug that into an equation and
when you
do that and i did this for it's it's the
um the twin brothers that went into
space by the way this is not
a special calculation anybody with
rudimentary knowledge
of einstein's special theory of
relativity can calculate this
right okay what i mean by rudimentary is
it's like the first equations you learn
in relativity 101. okay yeah too bad i
didn't too bad i didn't take that in
in school relatively 101.
you know uh so
and i i don't remember i might have come
up with like a hundredth of a second or
something
uh for being at those high speeds for a
year
relative to his twin so we don't measure
deaths with that time precision
so for me to say he will live 100
seconds longer than his twin on earth
that's not a meaningful time difference
so you have to be traveling much much
faster than just mock
dozens you'd have to be traveling a
major fraction of the speed of light and
do that for a suspended
sustained period of time then you come
back days years decades younger
than your twin would have aged that'd be
cool
see yeah so fighter probably forget
about it right
so forget about it yeah uh yeah forget
about okay so
all right well there you go uh michael
it's a hundredth of a second so enjoy
that
um
all right this is uh
let's keep it simple here because i like
this question some since we
since we're getting into the questions
that we don't normally ever get to
right i might as well get to those
really like weird questions
this is ralph tsuchi and ralph from
facebook says
if you were to get a spaced theme tattoo
what would it be
no i don't have any tattoos okay so i'm
just you know i'm not the generation
where the only two kinds of people
ever got tattoos and it was bikers and
sailors
right right that's right popeye popeye
had a sale
too right yes is there any voice you
can't mention
so papi had a like i think it was an
anchor uh yeah
right on his forearms right right his
bloated forearms
so i thought he had some kind of arm
disease or something
yeah probably elephantitis yeah i know
something right right
so um so i'm just not a tattoo guy
primarily because there's nothing
i have that much confidence in
really i want to look at eternally
until i die i i want to be always be
able to
have a thought that's different from a
thought i had before
and therefore you don't lock in the
previous thought you continue
to put in new tap roots now i said this
to someone who had a lot of tattoos
oh no no my body is just the record of
those thoughts right well they that's
right okay that's one way to look
to to look at it i said i could write
down the record that's another way i can
do it
i have paper for that uh
so if i were to get one maybe it would
be one of these sort of
uh bullet-shaped uh rockets from the
1950s
you know with the fins oh yeah how the
you know just kind of
it's it's classically imagined right i
should say yeah that's not how
a comic book version of a rocket but
from the day no one would draw that
today
right and just because it was it's it's
comes from a time when we had very high
hopes and expectations
yes that our energy and investments
would continue
into um space and
be sustained in ways that we have not
lived up
so that would be a that's how i think
about it
all right actually it's kind of a cool
tattoo all right i'll give it i thought
you were going to be like you know
saturn or something like that
oh no no i could look at pictures of
saturn which would look better than any
tattoo that would ever land end up i
mean
this is true this is true yeah okay all
right let's
go to okay
uh keeping with the same theme of the
the stuff we never asked okay
uh this is megu31 and instagram if you
can time travel
uh what's the one place uh you'll go
and the one person you'll see
so i assume they mean backwards trying
to uh yeah yeah okay so there's a
there's an old joke about that
right oh yeah so so consider the two
facts uh
if backward time travel were possible
wouldn't we have met such a person by
now
if wait if backward time happened was
wouldn't we have met such a person by
now what person
a backwards time traveler oh yeah yeah
they should have come here
to us all right they should have said
but but you know the the whole
um the prime directive of time travel
is that you're not a little captain kirk
yeah it's that you're not allowed
to upset the timeline in any way and
you're not allowed to tell anybody
you're a time traveler oh
that's how they hide among us oh
forgot about that right well okay
so one of my favorite
was it during the science march on
washington shortly after
trump was elected president there's a
science march just
in praise of science and one of the
placards said
they started a chant what do we want a
time machine
when do we want it it doesn't matter
right
that's it i like that isn't that good it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter whenever you get it
we'll move back to whatever we want
exactly
all right so uh if i could move back in
time i
i would go back and have a conversation
with isaac newton
okay so now that we know that uh and
that's that's well
and he lived you know i have to go back
to uh 16.
late 1600s the year 1700 would work
okay he had already discovered his laws
of optics gravity and calculus and
laws of optics are still getting
assembled he
discovered them but he hadn't published
it yet and
i'd bring some of our problems let's see
no now
now okay so this is fascinating to me
right now all right
i don't know how much time we got but i
got to jump into this for a second so
here you are
you're back 1700. talking to uh uh
uh isaac newton
now you know everything that he's
already done
yes isn't that interesting but he
doesn't you
also know things that he would find
wondrous yes how do you have a
conversation
what do you talk about when we come back
you might
end up screwing everything up
when we come back details of my
conversation with isaac
newton that i may or may not have
already had on star talk
we're back start talking cosmic queries
of course
chuck is sitting right there because and
you're here because you named this one
this because this is a potpourri but
you're not you're not happy with
popularity no we went with the cosmic
cauldron
cosmic cauldron yeah i was thinking
cosmic crucible but that's not right i
like the crucible that's even no you
burn stuff
that's very alchemic it is yes exactly
we have the alchemy the cosmic alchemy
we're putting this stuff in the crucible
and
burning away the bad and leaving only
what we need
so we we left off uh with
the question about who
who would i meet or what what would i
witness if i could go back in time
and definitely i'm going to meet isaac
newton
year 1700 is as good as any uh in his
late in his middle years
and but you posed an interesting point
right
like this stuff that i know because i'm
trained in physics that he's already
discovered that's right but then there's
stuff i know that he has he
hasn't figured out yet right and he and
he will figure it out
okay so now i just this is everything
you could screw it all
up just disturb the space-time continuum
yes it reminds me of my fate one of my
favorite episodes of the simpsons which
has been on tv for so the simpsons okay
it really does homer simpson uh somehow
turns a toaster into a time machine
and every time he goes back in time and
comes back there's something different
because he keeps disturbing the
continuum
and oh he disrupts what the flow of time
right okay
and one time all he did was step on a
bug and then he comes back and
everybody's a lizard person
i gotta find that episode it's very
funny
and then he comes back and um
everything looks uh the same except it's
super boring
or something like that and he's like oh
i got to get out of here
and it goes and right after he leaves it
starts raining doughnuts
[Laughter]
so that toaster is actually access to
the multiverse yes that's what's really
going
on there so here's here's an interesting
uh issue it's a time travel issue and it
has to do with what are called
gin particles in this particular example
it would be a gin concept
so a gin particle spell it's jin is the
is how you
it is something that was never created
nor
destroyed it just exists nice
okay so let's in the more classic movie
classic example
let's go to back to the future okay
right and back to the future
marty at the school prom right
gets a hold of the guitar right and then
he starts
imitating chuck berry okay
but marion barry is the bandleader
chuck berry's brother marion barry hears
this tune
and say chuck here's the tune you've
always been trying to figure out what
would work
and he puts the phone up to the thing
and he hears marty
that's joe okay and so now if we
follow that through what we are led to
believe
is that chuck berry got his most
brilliant song
from a white one yeah exactly
not from michael j fox no but what
happens is
so if he does actually get it from
michael j
fox and he then
influences michael j fox in the future
then this song only exists
in this loop it was never
written by anybody right do you see what
i'm saying oh yeah that's the only way
it could exist
it was never written by anybody it was
never written right
because uh marty plays it because he
heard it sung by chuck berry chuck berry
hears it for the first time
through his brother's putting the phone
out on the thing and then
chuck berry includes it in his right in
his performance as well as the
the the duck walk the duck walk
so so in the case with isaac newton it
would be interesting
if newton is on some calculation and
he's struggling i say
hey have you thought about if you
considered right hey
isaac isaacs i don't i just carried the
two
just carried the two isaac they forgot
to carry it forgot to carry the two
and so there i am helping isaac and then
of course he's remembered for doing it
but i only know it because i read that
he had done it and so again that would
be something that's closed in a time
in a time in a time loop basically that
never had a beginning or an end so it's
just an interesting
little fact about that i love that the
gin particle nice
yeah yeah yeah
it's a gin concept so for example in the
movie the lesser scene movie but it's a
slow romantic uh uh
not a rom-com but what do you call them
if it's just a romantic romantic movie
okay that's a romantic movie it was
called somewhere in time a love story
somewhere in time
it's a love story it was a love story
and i think i told this that some other
occasion yeah you told me i know i i
think where
an old woman comes up to the main
character who happens to be
christopher reeve who played superman no
he didn't we never talked about this
we never talked about this and she comes
up to him he's a professor and he she
gives him a locket
and says come to me oh no we never
talked about that and he finds out
that she come to she's back in time like
the 1920s
or 1930s and he does research on this
and finds out that this woman exists
at another time and he goes to a physics
professor
and uh colleague and says there anyway
go back in time so we'll try this and do
this he goes back in time
and he brings this locket with him and
he does
meet her and they do fall in love and as
a gift of his love for her
he gives her this locket well he didn't
love her that much that was her locket
[Laughter]
he didn't spend the time
because that in that case that's a gin
particle where the locket was never
created
or destroyed and it doesn't exist before
it appeared and it doesn't exist
after it only exists within that time
it's locked in time between when she
gave it to him
and when he gave it to her interesting
at an earlier point yeah
so that do you have to just watch out
for that yeah so now what do you
what do you ask him what do you say to
newton
i say please help so i got a problem
yeah the problem is there's a lot we
take for granted not just i but any of
us
living in the year 20 in the 21st
century we just take for granted that we
understand energy which was a poorly uh
uh
formulated concept in his day so he
wouldn't even know what you're talking
about
how'd you get i took a car what's a car
it's a horse-drawn carriage without the
horse well how did it move
through chemical energy well what's
chemical energy well he'd be a fast
study
yeah but i have to invest a lot of time
catching him up on things that we just
live with i don't like this i don't like
this
here's what that's because he's your
hero yeah
he's the guy that you love yeah he's got
a beautiful mind
yeah and after you talk to him for an
hour you're gonna be like listen dumbass
[Laughter]
newton
i don't like this i don't like it okay
that could upset my hero
the hero worship right anyway so that's
what i would do
all right there you go here we go all
right what else you got let's go to
austin media austin c
media from instagram says hello my name
is austin and i live in upstate new york
i work in the aerospace industry and i
build
giant hyper rockets
my question is based on rocket telemetry
as the earth rotates to east
as we launch rockets to east uh and use
the earth's gravity to help it get into
orbit
does the amount of gravity assist come
from just
the overall mass of the earth and its
speed
of rotation or does the mass of our
iron core help with the amount of
speed of the rotation in relation to the
amount of gravity we feel
so okay it's got nothing to do with any
of that okay
there you go that ain't got nothing to
do with any of that it's much austin
we're going to treat you like
isaac newton right now
no that's a rocket scientist
overthinking the problem right
okay okay is it possible to think too
much
just just rain that in a little bit let
that break brain calm down
just calm just just just take a
cleansing breath
okay so uh clearly he knows and others
might not know
that it is our preference our anyone
who's launching rockets to launch east
okay because earth is rotating
west to east so you get assist
and you're getting a little it's not a
gravity so it's not a gravity it's just
getting
it's a pure speed it's a push a little
speed assist a tailwind that's a
tailwind
a little tailwind for the rocket
so and and as such if you want the
maximum
uh extra boost you want to do it where
earth is
actually moving the fastest obviously
earth is spinning as one solid object
but at the equator it does one full turn
in the same time it does uh closer to
the pull but it's got a bigger distance
to travel
it's therefore moving faster you look at
the equator it's going about a thousand
miles an hour
we're here in new york city we're moving
about 800 miles an hour due east
so generally you want to launch as far
south as possible
they have some mobile launch platforms
that go pick up your rocket
go to the equator and then launch it
from the equator it's kind of cool wow
nice um it's a business it's a business
model
so anyhow if you do that then you don't
need the fuel
necessary to have gapped that extra
uh speed boost that you got so it's a
matter of safe if
you say fuel now i have more payload
capacity for the thing you're paying me
to put into orbit so everything is
better
okay if you if you can take less fuel
right and it's not that much less fuel
but it's enough you can make incremental
differences in your profit margins right
that's all it's got nothing to do with
the core it's got nothing to do with how
strong earth's gravity is
um that's extra speed is just this
whiplash
effect that's the rotation itself that's
that's all it is
and the speed with which you have to
attain
so that you can maintain orbit that
depends on earth's gravity
and for earth it's about five miles per
second
if you go a little less than five miles
per second you'll go up and then crash
back down
all right so you want to go fast enough
so that your eastern motion
it you want to go so fast that as you
fall back to earth
earth's curves away from you so for
every five
five feet let's say you fall towards
earth you move so far downstream
that earth's curved shape has curved
five feet away from you
so you're constantly falling towards
earth
at a speed where earth is exactly
curving away from you
that is the orbital speed and for earth
it's
18 000 miles an hour comes out to about
five miles per second wow there you go
that's so cool
there you go nice ah absolutely all
right
gate philosophy i've been in the house
with my kids for a long time that sounds
really good man
sending them are you
you can make it a game he wants to go
into orbit today it's a dealer's choice
as far as i'm concerned
all right uh we are running out of time
so let's get to
kobe from youtube how come we're running
out of time i'm talking too much damn
okay go on it's okay uh does light ever
cease to move
can a photon be in a state of
momentumless relax
or does it continue to move indefinitely
um so i guess he has to be talking about
in the vacuum of space because we know
that
photons cease to move you know when they
hit your eye
right there they're not photons anymore
right they're not they become pockets of
energy electrochemical energy
right in your head all right so uh
photons we can slow them down
anytime you put them in a transparent
denser medium they go slower
so they go slower going from vacuum to
air it goes slower going from air to
water it goes slower going from water to
glass
it goes slower going from glass to
diamond
okay diamond uh uh light travels
40 of its peak speed in a vacuum wow
okay so now there have been some
experiments where they created a medium
where the light is really really slow
like you could practically watch it move
from one point to the other right so
what you're doing is they're boosting
what's called the index of refraction
the higher the index refraction the
greater the light will bend
as it crosses into that medium and the
slower it will move
okay that's why diamonds are so useful
as rings because you put facets in it
and the light goes in it bends so
severely that you can have
you can trap light enough so that it
comes out a completely different place
from where the white
light went in so it gives the diamond uh
the appearance of having a certain
radiance
right right if it only gave light in the
direction you sent it in then that's
it's because i have the light
right all right but if light comes here
and it goes out there and you see it
from that direction
it gives you the impression of something
highly radiant so diamonds have value
for that reason uh among others but uh
for as jewelry their value for that
reason
so all i'm saying is uh in principle you
can have the index refraction so high
that you can like watch the lights
sort of move but i don't know that you
can just stop it
i don't think so so no frozen light i
don't think so damn because that might
be
so cool frozen light i don't mind
i don't mind the molasses light either
that's kind of cool that's kind of cool
too in fact there's a laboratory caltech
that specializes in high-speed
photography
and they have some camera that takes
like a trillion frames per second
and then they put light through a medium
that slowed it down and then they you
can take all these frames per second you
can actually
watch the light move that's amazing
right right that's good
i don't think you can stop it that in
fact let me put let me say it another
way i don't want to be around if you
succeed
i don't know what oh that's funny
time for one quick question what what
what do you got okay quick question
all right all right okay here you go
this would be very quick
daniel 220 from youtube says if aliens
are real
what technology can we suggest that they
have in other words what what technology
do you think
they would have example like a dyson
sphere
uh is there anything that is there
anything that we
first of all if they can get to us thank
you that's that's
the jig's up i mean
if they could get here because i mean
it's not like we can't see what's around
us
we know how close stuff is right here's
the thing
here's the thing i wield things in my
back pocket
that would have me burned at the stake
20 years ago for sorcery
in our own in our own civilization
okay if you if you've had the smartphone
in like the 1990s right
is that oh wait a minute let me do these
19 other things people would look at you
what
is that and that's just
us in our own technology in our own time
that's funny now you want an alien who
got here
from another planet from another galaxy
and you want to say do they have a dyson
sphere
if all you come up with is stuff we've
thought of that they might have
that's not creative enough right okay
because everything they do is going to
be more interesting than anything we can
ever think of because we're doing stuff
today
that's more interesting than we even
invented right
you look at the movie 2001. uh back then
computers were getting uh more powerful
so that the the the but because that was
1968 imagining the year 2001.
so computers were just coming around you
see computers and they get big and
powerful so in 2001
they'll be really big right they'll be
huge they'll be huge
and no one is imagining that you'll be
carrying computers with you
right they're not carrying a computer
but they're trying to imagine the future
all i'm saying is we we can barely
imagine our own future
with the technology sitting in front of
us much less
predict what kind of technology the
aliens are going to have
but if i had to go there i'd say yeah
they got warp drives and they can do
what the hell they want
there you go that's it that's because
that's what we want they have wardrobes
and we want that yeah
it's funny you say that to a joke where
i say if you had an iphone and you went
back
in time just 300 years they would have
burned you at the stake for
witchcraft unless you were a man in
which case they would have worshipped
you as a god
or if you go back to slavery times wait
black holes aren't supposed to be that
smart
you know i'll kill that one that's a bad
example absolutely
all right that's another cosmic queries
these are fun thanks for just being a
part of it thank you
yeah yeah definitely all right this is
uh cosmic aquarius
star talk neil degrasse tyson chuck nice
we're all here for you
[Music]
you